a la reelección presidencial una
tentación que pocos rechazan el popular
presidente del salvador nadie buque le
quedó habilitado para un segundo mandato
presidencial magistrados de la corte
suprema de justicia decidieron revertir
un fallo de 2014 que prohibía la
reelección argumentaron que la
interpretación es errónea
órdenes el tribunal supremo electoral
dar cumplimiento de la presente
resolución que una persona que ejerza la
presidencia de la república y que no
haya sido presidente en el período
inmediato anterior participe en la
contienda electoral por una segunda
ocasión
bukle inclusión en la política con un
partido de izquierda en 2012 y prometió
ser un político renovador fue alcalde de
nuevo cuscatlán donde donó su salario
para financiar becas universitarias
entre 2015 y 2018 fue alcalde de la
capital san salvador pero sus
diferencias con el partido que lo
impulsó lo llevaron a fundar su propia
agrupación política denominada nuevas
ideas
su imagen mediática dirigida a los
millennials lo hizo ganar popularidad y
se convirtió en presidente en febrero de
2019 al año siguiente su partido ganó la
mayoría de alcaldías del país y de
escaños en la asamblea pero sus
retractores lo acusan de llevar al país
hacia el autoritarismo en febrero de
2020 bukele se presentó ante el congreso
con soldados para presionar la
aprobación de un proyecto de ley que la
oposición bloqueaba luego destituyó a
los magistrados de la corte suprema y al
fiscal general por diferencias políticas
y ordenó el uso de fuerza letal para
enfrentar a las pandillas
recientemente aprobó una ley para que su
país adopte el bitcoin como moneda en
curso legal lo hizo sin consultas
técnicas ni jurídicas
pese a ello el 86% de los salvadoreños
aprueban su gestión ahora queda esperar
si buque le usará el camino a la
reelección y se sumará a la lista de
presidentes latinoamericanos
seducidos por sentarse más tiempo en la
silla presidencial